it was such a dream to work with Sandra
we had the script we didn't know which
sister we were going to play I got on a
phone with Sandra pretty much like
please I am not going to let Mom ruin
your life immediately you guys felt like
sisters I told you I
ran literally the dream team win or lose
we'll do it together and it all started
from this haunted Airbnb in London the
woman in the apartment above me at
random points of the day I would hear
her just like bloody murder scream I
remember when I first told you about it
Sandra you got like kind of a panicked
look on your face cuz you were like that
could be me Sandra was like that was me
unless you want to like sell your eggs
we need to get to Philadelphia I've been
so eager to actually talk about how
great it was to shoot this we got so
close I call her when I I'm just in
distress she feels like a real Jenny to
me I feel like we make a pretty good
team uh yeah we
[Music]
do